大家好，欢迎各位。大家今天怎么样？这将是一堂
非常棒的听说课。我很高兴大家都能来。欢迎
各位。就像训练肌肉一样。大脑不是肌肉，但我们建立
连接。我们建立更强的连接，所以我们今天的目标是让你们的
回答尽量做到自然、流利和清晰。你们可能注意到我会在你们说话时
打字。请试着看看我做的一些修改，
其中一些只是对你们或许可以表达得更好一点的说法进行了调整。
这会提高你们的流利度。但我不想它打断你们的发言。
请尽量专注于自然、流利和清晰。总的目标是
理解和被理解。这里有一个问题。说英语时，你已经对哪一点
感觉良好？我不知道。这可难倒我了。好的，所以我想
现在我说英语的时候，如果有人纠正我，
我不会觉得尴尬。所以我想这是我现在感觉良好的一点。
这确实是经验积累的结果。这确实有帮助。下一个问题，你认为
英语面试中哪个方面可能具有挑战性，为什么？我想
可能是新的词汇，而且我必须表达，或者像您提到的，
努力把我正在思考的内容用更清晰、更简短的方式表达出来。
简洁。是的。好的。努力把事情说得清晰而简洁。
好的。我同意。所有这些事情也都可以通过多做来改进。所以我们
可以在今天的课程中尝试改进我们说话的方式，使其更清晰或更简洁。
他们最常问的面试问题之一是
“请介绍一下你自己”。他们希望你敞开心扉。他们希望你打破冷场。
他们问过这个问题无数次了。有些人用这个问题来
给对方留下深刻印象，或者像我说的，打破冷场。他们真正想要的是什么？
他们真正想要的是简短的介绍，对吧？一到两分钟。一个关于你的专业背景、
你的技能、职业目标的有针对性的总结，这些
他们需要了解的基本信息。为什么？因为如果这是第一个问题，
他们需要对你有一个非常好的、非常强烈且积极的第一印象，
对于他们问的第一个问题。这里有一个关于你梦想工作的活动。在你的“介绍一下
你自己”的回答中，你会强调哪一到两个关键成就或技能？
你会强调哪两个技能或成就？我想
会是与决策能力相关的。然后另一个我想会是
关于，我不知道怎么说……就是当你自学 (zìxué) 某些东西的时候。
所以一个技能是你擅长做决定，另一个是
你很了解自己。另一个是，如果
我不知道某件事，我会一直查找直到我知道为止。好的。而且我
会尝试自己学习，在我……靠自己。是的，所以在寻求帮助之前，我会自己学习。
靠自己学习。所以你认为自己是一个有自主性的人。
你能够独立自主地工作。是这样吗？是的，我
两者都可以，但是，是的，我会先尝试自己解决。而且我认为这会
突出你能够做出正确决定的能力，他们将不必对你的工作
事无巨细地管理，他们相信你能找到正确的答案，
你不会成为他们的负担，并且你拥有必要的技能。我认为这是给人留下
良好第一印象的好方法。
嗯，是的。所以我们有一些不同的短语可以用来回答这个问题。
例如，如果我要向别人介绍我自己，我会说我的名字是戴维·布朗。
我对作为第二语言的英语教学充满热情。
我与来自世界各地的学生进行了大约24000次在线课程。
我教过初中和高中的年轻学生，
我对我所做的工作有很强的认同感。在我的空闲时间，我也会思考它。
我喜欢和家人朋友共度时光，并梦想着新的
技术。我不知道。如果我稍后有一个工作面试，我可能会这么说。
诺玛 (Nuòmǎ)，告诉我，你认为这会给人留下一个好的第一印象吗？
是的。哦，我希望如此。我不知道这节课对我更好还是对你更好，
说实话。谢谢你。谢谢。诺玛，这节课是免费的。好了，那么是什么让
那个例子容易理解呢？我想我可能说得有点太快了，但是你
怎么看？是什么让那个例子容易理解？不，实际上，我
听到的是关于您所拥有的经验。
而且我还能看出您可以胜任的年龄段范围。所以
我知道您可以和年长或年轻的人一起工作。而且您还是一个
照顾家庭的人。好的，另外，是的，你已经具备了很好的听力技巧。
我，与其说“我听到的*”，你可以说“我，我听说的”，
更确切地说，你可以说“我听到的是关于你所拥有的经验，
并且也了解了你可以胜任的年龄范围。所以我知道你可以和更年轻或
更年长的人一起工作。”我完全理解你的意思。好了，那么我们还有
另一个非常重要的问题。当被问到“你的优点是什么？”时，
这总是会被问到。我们有机会大放异彩。我们可以向别人展示我们的实力。
诺玛，你的优点是什么？所以你可以，但是，但是这必须是具体的，对吧？
因为我们可以，我们可以告诉别人我们是一个好的倾听者，
但是你什么时候是一个好的倾听者？在什么情况下你可以更具体一些？
这真的很有帮助。如果你能展示具体的，具体的
例子。然后当你被问到，“你最大的缺点是什么？”你可以
选择一个你正在积极改进的、真实的、次要的缺点。这样就表明
你很诚实。他们说你应该避免像“我是一个完美主义者 (wánměi zhǔyì zhě)”这样的陈词滥调 (chéncí làndiào)，
除非你真的能拿出证据来支持。你真的是一个完美主义者吗？